hello
[Music]
can you guys hear us
i don't think we're live yet
it takes a second
there's a delay
oh okay
whoo i tried putting my contacts in and
my eyes hurt
dad i don't think people can see us
oh
okay you guys could see us right
this is going to be poggers like the
great depression yeah that's the
i mean it wasn't it wasn't really
poggers but you know
i guess
relatively yeah
well
hi hi everybody hi core yeah you can
hear me swagger is it loud enough
because i got the mic way up over here
you can see me
you can hear okay
hello okay well that's good
yeah it looks like we're on so
what are you gonna carve the
pumpkin no
i thought you were running this wait
what are you doing you can't just stab
it oh my god
all right i've only done this one time
before you know that
i know yeah but
first we have to um
okay so it does work all right
so today we're gonna be doing
spooky halloween stuff and
i'm getting ahead of myself
i'm getting it you have to draw it first
that's for nerds guys come on
that's uh that's not for us
why don't you why don't you all tell us
about how your how your lovely morning
is going you 56 or so people
um
nadia why don't you tell the the
audience these people out here
what what's going on in life
um
life is going good
just a lot of halloween
a lot of orange
a lot of coffee
a lot of
jake
you say it like it's a bad thing
um
time zones are adorable um yes
um
i'm glad you're having a nice morning
um
there's it's halloween time i'm i love
how you look really pretty and like your
hair is lovely and everything and i'm
just here like
i mean i wouldn't say disheveled goblin
unless it worked truly i mean i truly
look quite disheveled i mean
it looks like i rolled out of bed that
looks like i live in a
the black lodge you know great
and uh jake's um jake just had his
contacts on and he rushed to the
bathroom because his eyes were burning
so
all right we have people reading eye of
the world we got halloween equals
poggers yeah that's what we like to see
because it is pogba's
um
the most most wholesome couple that's a
high standard i don't know i don't know
if you can fit that
um what a chad
i've been called many things in my life
chad is not one of them uh it's actually
my name is i don't know what is that is
that a slang
it's a meme oh
she's a boomer
[Laughter]
um
yeah so as ice burning on halloween
that's a bad omen i hope not this is my
last night of work i i uh
got to get through that should i tell
them where i work
sure if you want to i work at halloween
horror nights um
at universal studios so
if you were there
i probably scared you at some point
oh my god um
yeah you just as terry goodkind oh that
is scary
my goodness
hey potato
boo oh whoa i thought we weren't gonna
have jump scares come on potato
what's the deal with that
thanks for the five potato i sound like
a twitch streamer that's crazy i hope
you're having a lovely halloween
uh potato is uh just
i don't know do you think i'll go as a
potato
yes
we'll see
hello all yeah it's good to see you all
like existentially scaring yeah
how much to donate for you to shave the
pubic hair i mean beard wow
that is hurtful
um
probably
anything over twenty dollars so
sadoni it's okay
um i just started malazan anybody read
it i i haven't read it
are you still yeah so basically what
happened is um sedona come here i have
zero time this month uh there's
absolutely
no time
for anything uh
i've barely had time to keep up with my
school reading but um i hope to finish
song with susannah next month i actually
really like it i'm almost done with it i
don't know why i just i just got
distracted horribly distracted
uh
how many wheel of time books have you
read i'm on book three still i know
that pumpkin is actually
right it is stunning it's a stunning
pumpkin
um can you show us doggo please virtual
hug can we
yes oh
here's our baby
she is a sweetie
yeah you like this pumpkin
nadia would make a fantastic lily
monster for halloween lily monster billy
munster it's a character i don't know
what that is
okay i'm gonna start drawing why you
wait what
are you just gonna take over you're not
what is that yeah that's horrible
that's an eye yeah when you're turning
around
that's one eye
this is her idea of an eye that's a huge
eye
hey you know what
not everyone understands genius
my god when am i going to read a song of
ice and fire uh when it's finished
probably
i mean maybe not but we'll see this is
horrible this is so bad idea to only get
one pumpkin
no we need to draw on the other side the
eyes are too big how about i take over
this side you take over the other and
then we have a vote yeah okay please
i will draw one side i'm gonna do mine
it's gonna be a surprise and then you
can and i will draw on the other you
guys can vote on which one we actually
carve
yeah
damn jake so never then
no no we will we will
um spikey eye you like spiky i know it's
it's not okay
um don't we need to like get the thing
off from here
first right baby
i need to carve this out first okay but
you have to read chat while i do that
i can do it whoa whoa whoa
all right
no you got to angle it in hold on
it's got to be big enough to get my hand
in
i could do it too
all right
scoop the brains
okay someone said i am in the middle of
the first book i'm really interested in
some characters but the author
just keeps cutting away to characters i
don't care much any advice comments any
advice yeah for what
baby i just read it to you in the middle
of a book
ooh
ew look how gross
you
you
why aren't you spooked out spooky it's
very spooky
um
oh that's a stink
read that comment
um i'm in the middle of the first book
in berlin what book
what book oh is it malizan i think
oh i haven't started malzahan yet
i can't give advice
um
uh the traditional cook crooked pumpkin
smile is too overdone by now do
something new and creative with pumpkin
yeah so we're gonna have to have a vote
um all right so right now we're gonna
scoop i hate the scooping part so i'm
gonna have you do that is that okay
well i'm already doing it yeah because i
don't like what you got to take this off
it'll get all gross oh yeah
wait
okay
i hate scooping pumpkin guts it just
feels so weird with my fingers and hands
and
make the ooh face
how do i report you
how do i report you hey can i say
something i need to come to look no
controversial what
this is how i'd scoop you if you ever
cheated on me
i thought that was funny it was funnier
in my head
it's scary
[Laughter]
oh he's scared how cute yeah you think
it's cute um
it's the longest book i've ever read
dang i actually don't know
probably oathbringer
realistically just page count wise what
about the odyssey
no excuse me odyssey's got nothing on
oathbringer wait are you
throwing this away
doing it with my hands
why don't you just put it here because
then we can throw it out and this is
really awkward fine fine
all right
um
does it hurt that she's funnier than you
it hurts him all the time how do i
delete that
all right that's nice
how'd you like rebels creed um i really
liked it it was a great um i thought it
was a great expansion on the first book
and you guys should definitely check it
out if you like the first book
um
daniel has a really nice writing style
that's just very
it's very to the point and crisp and
doesn't get bogged down by pacing issues
really good pace
um
which book is longer let's bring her a
lord of chaos
i don't know
it's a good question
hire nadia for your jokes i mean i don't
hire her i just steal her jokes but
um
way better than bob yeah it was very
good and i mean breach of peace was good
but it was uh you know short
and this was a nice full novel um
that was nice
um
pumpkin eating pancake just stick it in
there what what are these ideas these
are these are these are beyond our
artistic talents frankly at least mine
are
um
donald green is threatening with a gun
right now um i mean i don't
i wouldn't know i mean he could be a
sniper i don't know
um stephen king equals poggers um yeah
i'm glad let's get that sentiment going
um
because i have a video out that's
something about stephen king um not
liking the wheel of time and that video
oh my god
talk about controversial i get comments
on that all the time either people
saying robert jordan's a terrible writer
stephen king's a terrible writer and i'm
like guys
let's meet in the middle somewhere
let's meet in the middle
uh who knew duncan idaho was an author
and a booktuber
um that what
healthbringer
oathbringer
okay oathbringer is longer than lord of
chaos interesting i'll dunk your idaho
doing pumpkin what what
your wit is too fast for me
my wit
have i read the dune prequels i have not
yet i've heard mixed things about it i
mean i think generally most people
aren't a fan of the brian herbert books
um
following your channel the three sci-fi
books for whatever reason vibe with me
to recommend you are babel 17 dahlgren
and tiger tiger have you read anything
i have not read um any uh
what is it uh
delaney i think that's delaney uh battle
17 uh in dahlgren i have one of his
books nova i think which i've been
looking to read
uh which i really do want to read
um
any halloween reads i'm reading hell
house right now by richard matheson
um which is really
it's really good i really like hell
house have you read that yeah it's a
metaphor for our place
that's the best you have for hell house
that's the best you have
okay how is this pumpkin stuff you're
taking so long why there's like there's
like five like seeds no i just threw it
in the trash honey oh okay it looked
kind of gross
uh two dollars uh is it gay to kiss your
homies good night uh good question john
no
it's it it can't be if you watch
it's totally pogress it can be if you
want but it doesn't have to be because
they're your homies you know
um but excellent question we need more
questions like this a very good topical
questions
um read i am legend a few months ago it
was good uh i haven't read that one yet
but i want okay you don't need to read
that you already say that in the mirror
every day
all right
that was good come on pogba's pop let's
do sapauger for nadia here that was a
good one i'm very poggers i talk about i
am legends because i say that in the
mirror already enough come on come on
that was so good he's making fun of me
i'm not that was actually good
i like that one it's better than hell
house
see you're getting poggers
yeah i'm poggers uh-huh
um
turning this pumpkin into poger stephen
king equals kissing your homies that's
right
good on them
um do you like eating tomato paste by
the spoon
um who is who why only when i want to
punish myself why
she's not eating as she goes along i'm
confused
[Music]
sorry we're not
we're going to harry potter's in uh
universal studios next week and i'm so
excited
what does pop yeah we are what does
pogba's mean um it's play of the game
right i mean i think that's what the
kids tell me
i actually truly i'm so old i have yeah
you're
yeah i married a 90-year-old
um i have not read all the dune books
and i have not seen attack of on titan
um i really i want to see cowboy bebop
that's coming out the the live should i
watch the live action first or the
the animated one you guys tell me
you are a fan of raw ginger
how would they know that
they know that you dyed your hair brown
what no the raw ginger like she eats
ginger all the time i don't know why
it's weird anime first raw ginger it's
pickled ginger that i eat and my first
i've not read martian or hail mary i i
haven't even seen the martian i've just
seen the scene with um
a donald glover with the pen ex
explaining space
i think
um
uh progress said anywhere else besides
twitch has how do you do fellow kids
vibes yeah that's kind of my vibe you
know how do you do fellow kids i am
on youtube after all over the age of 20.
um how do you do fellow kids
um watch the anime first yeah all right
all right i will watch the anime first
have i read any vonnegut yes i have read
slaughterhouse house five a long time
ago um i've actually been wanting to
read more vonnegut uh lately yeah yeah
so dhoni what's up how is this going do
you want me to get in there does this
look progress enough for you
tell me how
to give me the poger rating
oh my god
it's
it's like a three come on
all right this is what all right how
abused in this relationship that's is
that thorough enough because i don't
think that's thorough enough
you need a little bit of showing you
inside the pumpkin is is this does this
violate tos guys
is this violating tos no they like
getting in there
[Laughter]
nice stove thanks yeah
thank you for doing all the heavy
lifting all right guys i'm gonna really
get this scooper in there get really in
in there okay
and i'm just gonna try to clean this out
as well as possible oh my god it's so
wet
all right you gotta read chat while i do
this
all right
uh
get the stuff at the top that's dangling
but if you get all that stuff it's not
like
it's not like this is our most
disturbing stream
it's for educational purposes
this is going oh my god there's like so
much in here hell yeah get it brother
what the heck there's like so much in
here you haven't gotten
i get
look at that that's called a job see how
much criticism i get
please put the dog in the pumpkin
i'm gonna have to respectfully decline
probably yeah respectfully of course
she's not saving the seed to roast them
later
eyebrow cough ah you know i i know i did
that growing up but it kind of takes a
while and also is it really worth all
the trouble
also don't you
where how do you do that
um you just lay them out and let them
dry and then you bake them
yeah but like the outside is a little
not positive
they're saying we need pumpkin dog
i'm having the time of my life good job
swagger dagger you have the time of your
life
carve a cat in the pumpkin to prepare
for your future cat yes no okay i could
highlight this comment
oh we're watching young frankenstein
after we we do this pumpkin
um
uh you guys like young frankenstein hold
on i want to hear cat stream when
convince him please i want to hear
everybody everyone tell me what are the
essential
um halloween movies what movies do you
have to watch around or near halloween
um
young frankie yeah can you can you click
on the
yeah baby sorry sorry
young frankie let's hear it let's hear
it what are the essential halloween
movies
okay
frankie weenie
frankenweenie oh frankenweenie's good
rocky horror picture show just anything
horror
shawn of the dead casper
pumpkin on the ritz
including on the wrist that's fran
frankenstein oh die hard the original
halloween film okay if people keep
saying dawn of the day if people see
keep saying christmas movies for
halloween moves i'm going to lose my
mind i love this beetlejuice oh my god
yes
beetlejuice is great halloween yes
harry potter three yes
oh focus focus yes
adam's family yes
home alone
oh my i'm gonna you guys stop saying
christmas movies i'm gonna lose it
halloween halloween
possession
possession i want to watch like a really
really scary movie
we watched the evil dead movies recently
we never saw those
it was really fun oh yeah the first
one's still really scary the first evil
dead yeah hey honey i think that's
enough i need to carve my stuff my art
my artistic well i need to draw my side
no baby you have to draw you have to let
me do mine because it's still not done i
mean it's like
look at how much i'm still getting leave
some character in there what do you mean
character
that's not right this isn't right you're
wiping it too clean evil dead are
classics yeah i love evil dead
mulholland drive okay
hauling drives good i'm ruining her
artistic vision no
devil wears prada oh that's actually
probably
personally it's a paranormal activity
for me i used to be so scared of that
jake isn't typing
i don't get scared by anything i don't
know
i'm not scared by any of these horror
movies like i don't think
do you know what scared me
do you know scared me was hereditary
that and just because of one scene mean
girl
all right all right honey all right
let's show them the pile look at that
that's pretty good yeah that is really
good okay and i think i think the hole
is done
i think we're good that's what he said
i'm not i'm not doing any more with the
whole
yeah honey
keep saying that
what
nothing
all right
hey did you guys see uh the new
halloween movie halloween kills
yeah no
silence
you guys don't have do you guys don't
stream peacock
everyone's favorite streaming napkins
please
okay
all right gang
all right are you ready to show your no
i have to carve it first no you you you
do the drawing first and then and then
we compare drawings to see which to do
what so we're only going to do one yes
of course all right
okay so for the record
wait i require a jump scare
love oh thank you oh that's so sweet
everyone go subscribe to katie books
um
great great fellow lad bloke
you know all the all the words yes shout
out happy halloween my friend
um here
all right so this is
nadia's design
yeah because that is literally
horrifying no it's not it's it's
halloween it's supposed to be horrifying
what do you want something cute in
halloween yes
goodness gracious
all right
if you want a shiver down the spine just
watch daniel green bathe his books again
oh yeah that was quite a shiver yeah
that was quite a shiver
carve both sides see
can i do no they just want to see chaos
they don't care if our pumpkin looks
good i know how these people operate
they literally only just want to see
something weird use the cover you guys
just want to see us ruin our pumpkin i'm
not going to let you guys let us ruin
our pumpkin your lunatics
that movie was so pointless jamie lee
just sat in the hospital and oh you're
talking about michael myers
the new one did you think it was
pointless honey i loved it
yeah but it was also kind of bad but i
love it
it requires another sequel excuse me
yes yes yes all right
jump
scares are just cheap tricks but i
respect your opinion
okay
oh my god have you seen sweeney todd
that was creepiest
i'll be your tap blank
don't say this comment don't don't say
that out loud
i'm serious
i will okay
um the scene in hindi the one beating
her head against the addict will stick
with me forever yeah yeah that movie was
just like a set that movie was just so
disturbing for
so many reasons
yeah
carbon evil guy winking frequently do
you guys all right are we ready to
compare yes i think let's just do it oh
man
i have to take a shower after this all
right guys so
let's
all right this is nadia's
uh
schematic okay
beautiful beautifully as you can see the
mouth is like a blob the eyes are
flowers
it's clearly too big it's not even
though it looks like a face
okay one eye is a flower the other one
is
a spiral okay
and then it has a beautiful triangular
nose that you can see is a little dipped
in all right
hey okay then the mouth has a clear
characters in there as well so all right
so
that
or i'm going for classic simple elegant
triangle triangle triangle and a regular
copying me
okay
vote which one jake or nadia
i would say i would say nadia
come on vote for me guys come on
i would say nadia remember how you
subscribe to the channel and all the
good memories and you know the nostalgia
come on
hey honey
you don't do mine stop saying nadia
hey
but do you both know she gets my
there's one jake oh okay fine there's
two there's three jakes half and half
it's beautiful and it's
the shiny
uh
nadia for sure
okay unoriginal hey
that's a lot of votes look at all these
jakes jake jake jake jake jake uh-huh
uh-huh jake you're just highlighting
jake and there's jake and nadia
jake and nadia you know what i'm gonna
do both sides i'm gonna start with mine
because i think mine won and if you
wanna join in and do yours that's on you
gonna ruin it it's gonna be ruined why
don't you pull the laptop closer so you
can easier for you to walk look at
comments baby while i do this
kind of you guys let me down
you guys let me down
all right while this all this is
happening while this thing is happening
why don't you guys tell me what you're
up to
uh oh let me know what you're reading
are you guys reading anything spooky
or halloween themed
i usually like to read a stephen king
book around halloween what are you guys
reading
yeah exactly there's so much sadness in
my face
i need some more because i've been
wanting to read more contemporary horde
do you guys have any good um modern
horror books that i should get into
i i'm like i i want to read um the only
good indians that i heard that one's a
really good
a horror book
that sounds racist
i don't think i don't think it is
um
reading the original dracula yeah i
actually i really love the original
dracula it's really good
waiting for creed by donald green to
come in yeah i'm i got a i got a uh
advanced copy but i'm still waiting for
my pre-order hasn't arrived yet
halloween party by agatha christie i
read uh murder on the oregon express
recently for class
mastering commander
yeah that's spooky spooky stuff
uh apparently um i i have those books i
need to read those soon
um read some joe hill yeah anything no
sriracha related yeah rose madder
um
nice nice thank you um
yeah rose madder i feel like
i haven't read it i feel like it's kind
of overlooked stephen king
i'm reading vandermeer's southern reach
trilogy that has some spook oh um i need
to check that out actually i've heard
about that
um i need to get into that
um
18th century nautical knowledge hell
yeah brother hell yeah brother um
my god i'm getting hassan's weird
energy genius takes so much time god is
everything going okay
yeah i'm thrilled i can't wait to see
i just
you just have an impeccable vision
um
yeah i want to start the stand too but
i'm i have so much to like it's stupid
how much i have to read i have to read
um no country for old men for class this
week oh and then you're gonna do also
the video with me
wow yeah which one
bridgette yes we're gonna make a video
together
but it's gonna be on a different channel
yeah there will be announcements and
whatnot yeah you want to tell them
well
we are in like the next
i'll say sometime in november i don't
know when um
when we both have enough time we're
gonna build another channel and it's
gonna be more so
well actually you know what i would love
to hear your opinion so it's gonna be
more so both of us
um
and it could also include vlogs it'll be
more movie reviews
um an analysis as well
what do you guys think about that
poggers
poggers in the chat come on
let's hear it
someone said uh coincidence that hassan
isn't streaming right now i don't think
so
no
right
the outsider um i watched the shows the
show was good i haven't read the book um
hey a lot of people said bloggers to the
new channel i think of course they are
new channel powers hell yeah
um
and someone said did she say bridgeton
yes i did say that i want like more
i guess i'm interested in a lot of like
movie analysis or show analysis i love
bridgeton
i love that show she showed it to me now
that was a good show
for oh some dark eyed lowlander said for
a video idea choose a best-selling best
rated book of each decade
that could be interesting
uh oh the new channel should be called
cat carrying thing
then jake is forced to carry a cat
which is awesome
yay sounds like it'll be a great channel
tower junkie
um
so jake and i are actually going to
be home
i do i like bridgerton
um i i genuinely did
i have some issues with it but it was
good
um
hey david how you doing my friend uh
just joined and heard part of an idea
lol are you making a new channel nice
poggers indeed
i'm starting to feel like pogba's is
becoming less ironic and more sincere
and it's making me feel
bad like
like existentially bad but yeah uh new
channel nadia is forming a new channel
that we will both be working on yeah but
it's mostly your channel
it's both of ours it's her endeavor
am i in endeavors
um
would really love more videos on the
dune books um yeah you know i've been i
have some plans in the work
it's been hard um these past two months
because of my work but since i will be
done with work after this month um
it will be uh better to get some longer
videos and hopefully
um but yeah a lot of the the memes and
the short videos they've that's been
kind of my
uh what have been relying on because
it's really nice to
to do some short videos um
how you doing
how you doing
yeah
isn't he just such a fantastic freaking
actor
isn't he like how i'm acting right now
to be all nice and sweet like how he
acts to be like so in love with me
right what like how he acts like he's my
real husband
when i'm really married to joshua
um the cuban missile crisis is not
powers i think you should do some
hilarious content for ken foles pillars
of the earth series ridiculously
dramatized historical fiction definitely
some
uh stuff in there um i haven't read
those uh god they're so long i just
it wouldn't be worth my time i don't
know pillars of the earth worth my time
yay or nay
let's let's hear some let's hear some
yays in the chat
um
will the channel have uh mctu lore
that's a good question
oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah also jake and i are
actually going to europe in december
so
we will yeah so we'll probably be
vlogging a little bit on that channel
if you exist in europe
come come say hi
if you exist in europe if you can if you
can figure out where we are you know
what okay so we're going to london we're
going to perag and if anyone lives there
or has visited there we'd love
recommendations on where to visit
hey uh
megan has asked do either of you do
creative writing
we both do creative writing oh yeah jake
is a fantastic writer
so is nadia i'm sure you will
you will
read his writing one day
i just write manifestos about you know
my
his want to
be that serial killer who kills his wife
no no it's just it's more political
manifestos about and inherits all her
cookies
are are you lore building right now
no
no lore building please
this is not the time or the place
um
yeah
yeah what oh what is my level of
anticipation oh i missed that i'm so
sorry yay oh we're getting yays yays yay
wait i forget what the
i know i asked yay or nay what did i ask
ya or nay for guys my
short-term memory is awful
what did i ask do you remember no i was
so
i said yay or nay for something
what was the yay or nay for honey you're
so not progress
don't
you're embarrassing me all right
someone please tell me
what the yay or nay for
cereal manifesto cookie
inheritance poggers hey honey honey
honey
well oh thank you dark guide lowlander
what what look
yeah you see this is a sharp object
right don't hold the knife by my eye
it's not a knife but look
how much
be worn next time you don't want to get
with my plan
are you threatening me
no you're carving it the wrong way the
blade is pushing along the way fine it's
mine
it's mine
you're facing the blade the wrong one
mine
i'm doing it for a purpose
all right
all right let's hear some more oh we
don't play d and d uh at least not at
the moment the what oh it was about if i
was guilty or not what
if you're in london totally recommend
getting a
a tesco meal deal and post online then
await the judgment of the british people
on if you did a decent job i don't
understand what this is but a what i
don't know if this is a joke
tesco meal deal i don't know what that
is i don't know can someone please tell
me i feel like he's he's
pulling my leg
[Laughter]
um
will wife's cradle series i haven't um
read those yet
norway equals poggers okay man carrying
thing fanfic and coming
you guys aren't ready for my stormlight
fan fiction because they're not ready
how's the pumpkin going yeah how's it
going oh why is it not working
come on i want to snatch this eye out
but it won't let me
thank you david
um
oh oh was it about pillars of the earth
oh that's what the a rna was about if i
should if it was worth okay thank you
guys that's
literally like so tired
i've i've been getting like two hours of
sleep at night it's been tough
what the heck can anyone help this
i mean not anyone you're the only one
here sorry i just feel like there's like
100 people in our kitchen right now
there's 100 people in our kitchen yeah
guys come on help get this out
you haven't finished carving it baby i
did just act like it's debra come on
baby that's not finished carbon give it
act like it's joshua
baby it creates give me the
blade my goodness okay read chat i'll
get this out for you thank you
oh where are you
you should review wheel of time show
before it comes out and before you see
it fake review
it's actually a good idea bubbe you
should
before it comes out yeah
uh
dungeons and dragons deez nuts what
i could go for some
muddy stormlight lol
we need the kaladin fanfic yes we do
baby i got the rest okay all right
i did it you did it thank you i did good
i like it harry so oh no it's so
horrible yeah i like it harry okay oh
tesco is a supermarket chain meal deal
is a
sandwich and drinking snack
interesting so that's what we should be
eating
it's my real name robert
what why would it be robert what are you
talking about much better
lay up the devil's lettuce my man
good advice for all
and um for everyone laughs devil's
lettuce
uh when in london don't go trying to
find uh
ripper jacked what
um
catalan fanfic yeah
oh man i'll rip london's jack um
interesting comment
okay
thank you for your opinion
um
raucous applause
i'm so i'm getting confused by chad you
guys are starting to worry me
um
nadia called you
baby bobby what'd you call me
bobby oh yeah she calls me that
sometimes
my name is not robert
thoughts on brian sanchez author of
stormfront arcadia uh you know he's a
he's a lad he's a lad uh sounded like
she called you bobby
yeah i called him bobby
it's not
he calls me nano i call him bobby yeah
it's all good guys it's just don't worry
i still know his name my name is is
actually uh
fernando
i think we should just stick with mine
because
if you like
huh
don't call me robbie oh my god
um can't i call you rap i mean i guess
you can but because i don't really like
talk to you every day but yeah i mean i
guess it wouldn't really affect me it
would hurt his soul how goes magic
spanish civil war that's very the kind
that you remember what my
work in progress is called
are not called but what it's about um
okay
i'm ready it's going that's all i'll say
okay
are you ready
for the reveal
okay just keep in mind it's supposed to
be hairy okay no shaming body hair
all right
all right one
two
three
and put it down yeah
what huh huh
nice and hairy
it is looks like it is suffering
it's halloween of course it's suffering
it looks like
did you cut out the nose
no no i decided it shouldn't have a nose
nose is not poggers anymore
it is
it looks like it's
okay
okay poggers for gay no non poggers for
nay no wha what i don't know non poggers
yay or nay is it is it working out is
this it just looks so sad it's like
it's like
it's like this
you know what i mean
did i capture it
a lot of people say yay
i'm gonna screenshot that
i think we are
winning
i think it's pretty perfect
it's scary because it's so sad
perfect existential crisis vibes for
halloween
um yeah
i left for left before 15 minutes came
back and i think my dreams will be
haunted for a while
yeah i'm sorry guys this is
make that face the thumbnail
looks like he is suffering you guys
asked for this i mean i don't know i
don't know what you expected um
yeah it looks like someone just
it looks like somebody just shoved
something up its rear end hey
uh-huh
that face should be an emoji in the
server yeah yeah come on let's discord
let's get that going
um oh oh no my face is so many weird
things on that discord it
go join the discord if you guys have i'm
sure i'm sure all of you are
um
eve's face after that one talk with land
ah people who have read the books get it
well
what are you doing you you can't carve
what are you doing hey you didn't pay
enough attention oh my god she's just
carving the other side now
it's brutal has this pumpkin gone
through enough
oh
apparently not oh my god
um it's a terrifying pumpkin face yeah
how was mexico you know mexico was uh
i've we're still in mexico actually so
don't tell people
uh jake at the end of the gunslinger
improv my man improv i don't know what
that's in reference to but i'm i yeah
improv
uh boo
jump scares all right you wanted non
scary face i did it really quickly look
this is oh that's this is this is paw
patrol let me let me remove this
this is poggers
oh no this is halloween pogba stop
saying pogba's
this is halloween poggers
this is everyday poggers
it oh that looks kind of villainous
yeah that's what you want okay which
one's better come on
the halloween or non-halloween version
just say jake or nadia which one which
is the better
no i designed this no you didn't look at
your
thing but it generally designed it
okay fine this could be jake hogger this
could be nadia okay
jake
jake yeah people like
did you see it took me like 20 seconds
to do this
because those guys don't appreciate hard
work
okay just
it's the most
this is this is like a fun spooky this
is you guys think this is christmas what
the hell
that's this this is
now show the other side
the poger side
[Laughter]
that's what that is
i'm i got the facial expressions for it
this is called acceptance
um
this is called
stimulation you are a natural artist
that's really nice that they said that
of you
i am a natural artist yes it's hard
satan is a good guy and i stand by that
all right
um
it's the face off movie poster yeah
someone please make that like that
that'd be so funny are people still
saying jake
jake robert
won you know what if if that is what you
get is to be called robert as a winner
yeah this has been such an enjoyable
halloween
being called robert
fine let me make the non-poggers more
poger no stop it you're gonna oh my god
what are you doing giving
poggers making it poger stop oh my god
it was scary enough as it was are you
giving it eyebrows hey just don't spoil
it oh my
here
now it's more pogers do you see the
eyebrows right there
right there and right there you see it's
just lines it's not even okay you want
more okay more eyebrows
honey
now it's even less buggers yeah
excuse me bless you thank you
i'm so good at this we don't eat the
seeds that's uh
i don't i don't i used to eat the seeds
but it takes a while to do them and it's
just like there's i could have carl's jr
you know what i mean um
do i have an extra pumpkin no i just got
one i didn't feel like carrying two from
the grocery all right look
look how poggers it is
huh how many pumpkins have you seen with
an eyebrow huh
huh
now it's nadia huh now it's nadia
you know what you're gonna have to live
with this face
the eyebrows make it so much more in
candy valley like
we were like it was just scary at first
now it's uncanny valley it's like
you want more poggers no no stop saying
you want more poggers like that in a
threatening way
oh you want more poggers i should have
never taught you the word progress
looking kind of fresh can't lie
okay yeah
those are stress lines
um nadia is competitive
you have no idea look now it's more
poggers what did you do to it
cheeks it has rosy cheeks now you see
rosy cheeks
someone carved it you like it now don't
you someone just drilled a hole through
its mouth that's why it's suffering so
much it's called you know what it's
called this is called
um
i can't think of the word anymore
thank you
uh
she's gone mad with power seriously i
don't even need to be here on streets
tell me i'm poggers no tell me i'm
poggers no all right you want pogba no
oh my god stop
i'll get you more
there's not going to be any pumpkin left
you want it poppers
oh my god
chat please tell her this stop this is
concerning
not until i'm poggers no just stop
saying
pogba's look
now it has a nose and it has a hole on
the top right right there too huggers
and
[Laughter]
they're trying to get you to stop
they're negotiating like with the terror
the poger's okay
they're literally like fine
okay that sounds like a command yes
you're scaring them you're scaring them
it's halloween
oh my god fine
as long as i'm poggers am i poggers
am i popping yes yes okay
i'm blockers
now i'll wash my hand yeah while you
admire my pogers yeah why don't you wash
your hands guys
okay guys she's gone just tell me what
you think of the pumpkin
is it scary
it's totally pogged out now okay
wow
well i it you know it is um
it's it looks like it just looks like
swiss cheese now
but i guess
the eyebrows
oh my god
oh my god
ah this is this has been a lot this is
this has been a lot um
i need
nadia's looks like voldemort's face
melting yeah
um
the eyes definitely make it look scary
i think each face is genuinely good a
bit avant-garde on one side in class
what are you an art critic what is this
swagger dagger come on
what is this art art art class
no this is a monster this is horrifying
thanks for the no jump scares i mean i
guess i guess
say that
um
all right i'm back
did i miss the meaning of life yeah we
talked about the meaning of life earlier
actually guys can i hear can i hear the
meaning of life anybody have it please
tell me the meaning of life just want to
hear it
yeah let's let's smile
so scary okay read chat i'm gonna get a
candle
hey
are you gonna ruin my pogers i'm putting
a candle in it where are the candles i
don't know
oh recheck okay
why did people say 42 honey oh that's
the meaning of life
[Laughter]
it's definitely not that pumpkin oh
i'm gonna ignore that comment
the meaning of life is to breathe or
something
domestic horses mysterious origin
may finally be revealed
hey i like this comment hello pog queen
thank you i am the paw queen
that's right
ego boost for the day yeah
yeah as long as as long as people know
that i'm poggers and jake isn't i'm good
what is this hurtful like attitude
hey you know what i was okay for both of
us to be poggers it was you who wanted
to
you know say bad things you can't even
tell the
you can't even tell it's on what the
hell
baby let me let someone who's poggers do
it i did it's on baby it's because you
have the wrong handle let me just do it
why don't you get chitchat if i hear the
word progress one more time i swear to
god i'm gonna [ __ ] lose it we just
need a candle that's pogba
[Applause]
turn turn the light off i have a bunch
of lights on on yeah
you are so powers you just pop guys this
is i'm losing my mind this is like
causing this is going to give me like a
okay
okay i got pogbas can you not both be
i got this one with this see
oh that's longer that's too tall no it's
not one
that's way too tall we tried it your way
can you please can you please you can't
put the cap on yes i can
no it's gonna burn
i know burn baby burn no it's gonna burn
yeah burn baby burn no not in the house
hold on you're okay you're you're
she's losing it she's mad with power
people
yeah it's it's literally right on the
thing look at that it's burning it
to make it more poger no oh my god
no fire is burning things it's not
poggers
what oh my god this is getting out of
hand
you will dislike if you say one more
time yeah come on no more no more
nadia burning down your
this is this is the screen this is the
thumbnail no idea burning your house
down is not poggers
yeah please
um
please it's getting
[Music]
all right well
i need to hear some words of uh comfort
from you all um
i need to hear what you all are dressing
up today as if you're doing anything
what are your what are your halloween
costumes let's hear some cool ones
because um it's important
nadia is actually
what are you
doing what did i say i'm trying to make
things poggers
you don't want to hear it
someone smashed your pumpkin last night
were you listening to smashing pumpkins
nah
i'm sorry that that's insensitive i'm so
sorry that that happened to you
um
um
dressing up as an underpaid employee
working 412 yeah
same
uh same here
all right fine this is cruelty this is
[ __ ] cruelty
yeah that's not okay sandworm costume
poggers okay
uh
the meaning of life is death and getting
a cat well
that's a little simplistic i think
uh dressed as naive i only needed a
braid yeah
so this is a huge mess that's going to
take a long time to clean up um yeah i
have to go into work at what time four i
think you want to see creativity last
night at work
um
when i am i going to jump on a track hey
look what i made at progress
oh let's see sorry david i don't know
what that is
yeah
it's that's right
it is in so much pain
that's great i love you oh that is that
is kind word those are the kind words we
need more love in the chat less progress
okay let's hear some love no more pogers
alive beautiful
beautiful where do i work without real
revealing too much i work at universal
studios hollywood currently it was my
last time to work
um i can't say like where in the park
like which maze i'm at i think that's i
they don't let me do that but
um i could tell you guys all about it
after i'm done with the run
it's pretty fun i like doing it it's
i've been doing it for years
um
he has this like uh
this hollywood big shot yeah universal
studios hollywood
he likes he has this thing where
he likes to scare people and it fulfills
him
oh it's it's great i love scaring people
i scare so many
you know
it's actually kind of like therapeutic
scaring people at the you know at uh
at universal and stuff because um you
know you just you feel powerful you know
you get somebody to fall on the floor
just by spooking them out you know
do you see why deborah feels the way she
does about her what what
um
sounds like a cool job um yeah it's
pretty
it's pretty
exhausting
um
put that put the thing up baby this
looks gross
put the laptop up a little bit
okay
watching people suffer is therapeutic
hey they paid to go they paid to be in
the park
people pay to suffer they paid to get
scared i'm just fulfilling my job
sounds like a cool job yeah it's fun i
they let us go see some of the other
mazes last night i got to go see the
haunting of hill house that one's pretty
cool
um
yeah that's it's fun i like i like the
park they do a good job with their mazes
um
i i have not read all six dune books i'm
gonna read uh children of dune very soon
hopefully
um
i love you take but i can't hear pogba's
anymore i know i don't blame you happy
halloween check out a bit and see if
maybe uh the word has worn itself out
look what you're doing to people what do
you
honey
are you not listening to people i'm not
going to show you look what he
just wrote it's so sweet but like didn't
we say we wouldn't say proverbs anymore
it says nadia's pogba's jake
happy halloween you two have impeccable
chaos vibes as usual thank you thank you
guys for you know
the the love
um
don't serial killers say killing make
them feel like god
i'm not killing people for real just
pretend come on
um
but if i if it was for real i don't know
how i feel about that um
please scare us uh
taxes
was that a dad joke that's the dead
drill honey but yeah sorry i think
i'm gonna let you continue
yeah i think we're gonna wrap this up
how long have we been going an hour
one hour i think that's good all right
gang i need to hear uh all of your
final thoughts about
halloween about the the state of the
stream
um
yeah it's extra scary
um do i ever scare on twitch i don't
i don't have twitch
i don't need to get twitch i have too
much i don't know i can't even maintain
my instagram
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna leave with this
secret since it's halloween
about jake
he sleepwalks i don't oh
are we dressing up as anything
i mean at work i will but
i'm gonna put his clothes on and i'm
gonna dress up as him halloween is great
get into the spirit have some fun binge
or some candy your favorite candy and
just be you know sit on the couch and
watch a movie you know that's what
halloween's all about yes watch a movie
watch something scary and rub your belly
reese's best halloween candy that's my
thought no i love reese's laffy taffy
yeah laffy taffy or salt taffy it's all
taffy's good saltafi's good yeah see you
guys happy halloween thanks for the
stream thank you guys for coming thank
you
it's just
again i must say you know i'm
sorry for all the suffering that we put
this pumpkin through but no this pumpkin
is happy this is what life this is a
replication of life
this is the pumpkin
happy
this is a pumpkin
that's the best this is the best
halloween costume i agree
but um
yeah this is um this is good thank you
thank you all for coming
um yeah thank you um
dark gray lowlander
um 11 out of 10 stream 12 out of 10
pumpkin yeah
that's right
yeah that's what we like to see
no
no no
can't reese's are my favorites i agree
with you jake yeah all right bye bye
everyone thank you and um
you know
bye stay poggers no say poggers
all right i'm ending this
bye